Piazza appreciate this this is kind of
music here now that that next theme
music right therefore stat of the day so
that's what we're looking for that's the
bar set pretty high for who stance would
you want Mike Piazza joining us down
what do you think of that Mike kind of
chunky chunky yeah I like it but you
still let them you're you're a heavy
metal hard metal I'm you know probably
you and I are from the same era so I
would think at least for me when I you
know when I run now all my on my music I
listen to still a lot of 80s Van Halen
and obviously guns being on tour it's
good to hear them the ac/dc I mean I
listen to some of the new stuff Godsmack
is probably one of the I mean I don't
see they're a new band but one of the
more you know recent bands I listen to
and a couple others but how about
yourself I have a hard time finding
anything that's rock and roll now and I
go so I keep playing the same stuff from
the 70s or the 60s so that the stones
and Zeppelin the who or it just I keep
going back to that because I haven't I
don't feel like anybody's doing rock and
roll that much anymore I couldn't agree
more I mean I think the styles of music
effused you know together and it's more
about image I mean there's some great
musicians don't get me wrong I see them
from time to time but a lot of us change
man I think we're I think we have to
admit we're kind of dinosaurs yes the
surrender to it but you being a catcher
you got to hear all of that walk-up
music like when that guys coming up to
the plate was there one where you went
are you kidding me that's your walk-up
song well yes a few of the songs I mean
I went through my process some of the
songs that you think sound cool don't
really sound cool as you're walking up
the plate in in the audience setting at
the stadium I read a funny story one
time I think I don't not sure was a Tony
Tarasco when he's with
Yankees he played a a rap song that was
kind of obscene and it had some sound I
didn't know and I guess when over Yankee
Stadium I thought that was well
obviously not funny but kind of I got a
little chuckle out of that but yeah I
mean some of them are a little stranger
the Latin guys that play the merengue
very high high tempo merengue it may not
be made a little bit of a blast to some
people but you know everyone has a
different obviously their own tastes is
there any better song than Rivera Enter
Sandman no I mean I think obviously even
the band I mean I think the band even
honored him which is amazing the fact
that a pitcher obviously that's mean
with moap his record speaks for itself
and the fact that he almost yeah adopted
that song and it became the character so
to speak of that song it kind of reminds
me of professional wrestling you know in
a way that yeah you know when I was a
kid you know you'd come out you know
Jesse the body and these guys and they
would play the music and obviously Hulk
and Randy Savage you know will come out
to to which I really like was voodoo
child actually adopted that when when
Hulk Hogan and Randy Savage come on yet
when they did the they change they kind
came bad guys and it came out to that I
thought it was really cool we're talking
to Mike Beyonce we were wondering if you
have anything from the five games you
spent with the Marlins did you keep your
Marlins Jersey I did yes I have one of
them and it was funny because I think I
wanted the sleeveless version at that
time and I went to the equipment guy
when I got traded they said we're you
know cuz I always liked the old
Pittsburgh Pirates um you know
sleeveless jerseys and obviously I think
they they they patterned a little bit in
that style and I was like where's my
sleeveless Jersey and they were like oh
the club president I think with Dave
Sampson took it upstairs and I was like
well that's mine where is it so he still
has it today so every time I go to a
Marlins game I go to Dave I go where's
my jersey wait so this is before you
were traded or as you were being told
you were traded you wanted to Jersey to
take with you yeah I have a home jersey
actually I have in my house it's pretty
cool the one I did wear at home
then we had the sleeveless virgin
version which we were obviously like day
games in Florida which you have to and
so yeah when I went to got traded when I
was traded to the Mets I was getting all
my stuff together and I went to the
equipment manager and I was like I want
the sleeveless version they're like Dave
Samson already stole it or you know took
it upstairs and I think darn man I
wanted that one they shouldn't retire
your Jersey for five games well you know
I did go to the clothing of well not
clothing technically but when the
Dolphins then you know remodeled the
park that the Marlins were then moving
to the downtown park and I went there
and they had invited me and I said you
know what I mean because I live in Miami
so obviously I'm a local and they said
we don't care we think it's kind of cool
and I kind of surrender so yeah I
thought it was a it was funny I mean
people weren't we're stunned and when
the guy announced me I think it was on
the MLB special he said it was short but
it was sweet it was really cute you know
and the Marlins fans were like freaking
out they were laughing so hard so you
know they were like well we we don't
think you're probably gonna go in the
Hall of Fame as a Marlin but we enjoy
the week you and I have five RBIs in
five games oh yeah not a lot of people
you were you're on a hell of a base
there I'd I was on it how exactly I
would have driven in 162 runs if I play
with the Marlins in 1998 how close what
was it difficult in choosing the Mets
over the Dodgers to go in to the Hall of
Fame and oh well you know not really oh
I mean yeah III would I would lie to say
at the time obviously when I left the
Dodgers it was very contentious and
there was a lot of like really bad
energies coming together and I've met
freely admitted at the time you know
myself and Danny and we dug our heels in
and the Dodgers dug their heels in and
they were just sold to Fox and Fox
wanted to make a statement and we just
for some reason it was toxic it wasn't
any sort of synergy there and we weren't
able to work out an extension and and it
was just one of those things it's like a
bad divorce and it just at the time
obviously I wasn't happy but as the
years go on I mean I have no ill will at
all at the Dodgers and I never really
did I mean it took me some time
obviously because once I came to New
York
and did pretty well here it just was
bygones be bygones and that was it and
you know I mean again I love Tommy and I
went to when I was with Team Italy a few
years ago we were training at the
Dodgers camp and a lot of that old
Dodgers came up to me and said hi and so
was it was it was very nice but no I
mean you know that the look the Mets
stepped up they traded for me they
signed me and obviously having going to
the World Series here it was it wasn't
that difficult
do you understand the Chris Sale not
topic but just reaction to that Jersey
I'm like if you ever worn a Jersey where
you say I don't feel comfortable in this
or I don't like this and here's a
pitcher saying look I don't like these I
don't want to pitch in it and then he
takes a machete to the jerseys mm-hmm
well I mean I think that maybe he does
may have a grievance there that I mean
maybe it didn't fit well or he wasn't
comfortable but I mean obviously what he
did was out of line
I mean I don't think he you should do
that maybe if he felt it was
uncomfortable he could have went to the
equipment manager and said look can I
can I change this or sew this up real
quick or maybe stretch it out or
whatever I always thought the flashback
days were fun I mean I think I saw the
Phillies wearing the powder blue road
he's a few weeks ago and I thought it
was really cool so you know I mean look
I'm not I'm not going to say that he
probably didn't have a gripe and maybe
that made some sense but the way he
handled it obviously was was poor and
and there could have been a better
solution I think when I talked to you
after you've been announced that you had
made the Hall of Fame and I said that
you don't know what it's gonna feel like
you can practice that speech but until
you get in the moment you don't know how
that emotions going to affect you and it
almost felt like when you started to
read it deliver it it started to sink in
even deeper that in a major even more
emotional in front of that crowd well
absolutely and I mean it was funny
because I had done you know Jimmy Kimmel
the week before and I went on the show
and I said look I'm I know I'm gonna cry
I'm gonna cry and and he said he simply
attacks it was funny the day before and
he said real men cry funerals and when
they get inducted to space policy
and it was really funny no you're right
and I think you know when you think
about it that just the the in my kind of
theme you know it was kind of I had an
unofficial theme is that you do not go
in alone I mean and when I think at the
time so many people helping me and a lot
of times you don't even recognize it I
mean you don't I told the story about
Reggie Smith and at the time I was young
and I was was immature and and and
obviously disgruntled and and wanted to
quit the game and but he reached out and
and I said you know the biggest lesson
he taught me was not hitting how to hit
a baseball but the game of life and not
to quit and that that stuff is powerful
and it obviously affected my life
immensely from obviously without you
know from my father
the first contact of this game with my
dad and then on through the minors and
mentioning ek and Fonzie and guys I play
with a now and so that journey which I
really the response has been great the
people said man you took us on your
journey and it was really special it was
yes but it is a powerful thing and I'm
glad I was able to collect myself and
not you know cry all over the words how
was that phone call from Johnny Bench it
was awesome
you know it was really really awesome
and and you know I've already talked to
Johnny a couple times and talked to
Smitty and somebody's like you know I
don't want to bother you but you know
maybe hit the ball you know play some
golf
Alex many of you know my boyhood idols
like bother me you know what I mean it's
cute and it's so much fun and it's a
great club it's a huge it's a great
fighter natee and and the guys they
treat you like gold and and they
absolutely spoil us I mean you get you
and you get out of there you're like man
you know you feel like we're LT and it's
a really special Club and and you know
the traditions are amazing and I think
the whole did an amazing job and and and
personally I want to thank all the
people that came out there I mean that's
not an easy drive obviously from the
city to get up there and they really
made the effort and I'm just glad that
they enjoyed the speech you know very
much do you what do you regret more the
mullet the mustache or the frosted tips
or none of the above
well they well the good thing in bronze
you can't see it
so that's how they did put in I think
the goatee and the the mullet in the
back you know even the the artist who
did the plate was there when they put
installed it on Monday and he came up to
me and he said you know I wanted to put
a little bit of the hair in the back and
it looks great and so yeah it's uh do I
regret anything I mean look that was the
90s man I think you know I saw Randy
Johnson there he had a meghamala yeah
you know that thing that thing looked
like you know someone took you know Paul
Stanley hair and put it under his head
just you know and rattled it so yeah you
know and looking back and seeing it a
few of the guys that had the hair and
now you know not so much hold on hold on
to what you have for as long as you
can't exactly never never complain about
too much hair you know that one by the
way I got you one for three awesome over
there yeah yeah probably was a broken
bat zoom you know three you know pieces
all over the plane oh he was amazed no
it was a homerun
you don't remember hitting a homerun off
Mariano Rivera did oh really
oh my god holy is that right a quarter
of our research we have him one four
three career versus more Rivera with a
solo homerun really which ah you know
what I do remember that year was you
guys are supposed to remember everything
after now you can tell me the count that
you hit it off
no I think because I made the mat last
out against them in the World Series
after that I went to a deep depression
so maybe that wiped that whole homerun
sort of you know lore
I don't even remember what year that was
now that's crazy I might have just
probably I mean if he was in the game
you know I don't know if it really was
significant or tired or anything but I
got to look that one up that's something
all right so then I'm glad you gave me
this ammunition because when Mogens you
own obviously yeah you own - hey I'll
take the 333 against the great game's
greatest clothes bubble you know who you
owned I felt bad for this guy you know
who you owned you can tell me Hall of
Fame pitcher you owned it
there's a Pedro well Pedro's there but
poor tom glavine oh yeah yeah yeah Tommy
couldn't yeah you know what's funny I
have a few bombs off Pedro - is there
you got him and you got six off Glavine
mmm yeah no I
I remember Pedro you said throw me that
little cutter and everything else I
couldn't hit and I should just sit all
over that and he usually threw it to me
when I was a head and or behind in the
counts and so yeah you were waitin for
crap yeah hey congrats that was a great
speech great day and thanks for joining
us that was my pleasure I'll talk to him
at Mike Piazza old Famer the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience